Drip systems are great for efficiency in dry
and arid climates.
One thing to consider though, is the type
of soil that you have in your garden or landscape
that you’re watering.
Depending on the soil type, you will want
to select an emitter that matches that texture.
The different types of emitters will emit
different amounts of water over a given amount
of time.
Most of these range from 1/2 a gallon to 2
gallons in home and garden uses.
This is amount of water per emitter, per hour.
If you have a clay soil, you will want to
select an emitter closer to a 1/2 gallon per
hour rate.
These soils cannot accept as much water over
a given amount of time as compared to a sandy
soil, which can handle a greater volume over
time.
So, a 2 gallon emitter would be more appropriate
for a sandy soil.
The University of Wyoming Extension can help
in determining the type of soil you have in
your garden or landscape.
Once you’ve determined your soil texture
and you’ve set up your irrigation system,
you’ll need to run it for an appropriate
amount of time to make sure that you do not
have any major leaks, you do not have any
pooling on top of the soil surface – meaning
that you are over-applying water – and that
the water is actually going all the way through
the root zone of the plants that you are looking
to water.
From the University of Wyoming Extension,
I’m Brian Sebade, and you’re watching
From the Ground Up.